Hey! We are back with the
dimensionality reduction series.
In our last video of the series, we talked about
one way to escape the curse of dimensionality
through an older algorithm, called PCA.
Today we will talk about a newer and very popular
dimensionality reduction algorithm called UMAP.
PCA and UMAP are very different: PCA factorizes a
matrix characterizing the data, which puts it into
company with algorithms like NMF or SVD. But UMAP
(like t-SNE if you know it), builds a neighbor
graph in the original space of the data and tries
to find a similar graph in lower dimensions.
But how does it do it?
UMAP stands for "Uniform Manifold
Approximation and Projection".
This sounds intimidating. And the paper
behind it can be even more intimidating, but
do not worry, because we break it down for you.
The two steps of UMAP are the high-dimensional
graph construction and its mapping
to a lower dimensional graph.
The construction of this high-dimensional
graph is what makes UMAP so special
compared to its competitors, since
it's hard to do it right and fast.
And the cool part about UMAP is that its
steps are mathematically proven to work.
So first, there was the data in the high
dimensions and we want to approximate its
shape, or topology. Each data point is
a so-called 0-simplex. And a certain
theorem ensures that the shape of the data
can be approximated when we connect these
0-simplices (which are our data points),
with their neighboring data points forming 1-
or 2- or higher-dimensional simplices.
And with this, we can approximate the topology.
So all what we need to do
is make these connections.
For this, the UMAP algorithm extends
a radius around each point and makes
a connection between each point and
its neighbors with intersecting radii.
So far the radii are equal.
But remember, we want to
approximate the shape of the data, so we want a
connected graph containing all our data points.
But this whish of ours brings in two problems:
Firstly, it often happens that in the data
there are larger gaps, where there is no
next point to connect to in the graph.
This happens usually in low density regions.
Secondly, there are often high density regions
where there are a lot of neighbors in the given
radius and everything is way too connected.
This second problem gets even worse
with the curse of dimensionality,
where in high dimensional spaces the distances
between points become more and more similar.
Okay, so then, if we have these
two problems with a fixed radius,
then let’s use a variable radius instead!
This choice is also mathematically supported
by the definition of a Riemannian metric on the
manifold, but do not worry about that.
Just keep in mind that there is math
proving that the choice of a variable
radius does not cause any trouble.
So now the radius is greater in low density
regions and smaller in high density regions.
But UMAP does not estimate density
directly as a number but uses a proxy:
the density is estimated to be higher
when the kth nearest neighbor is close
and lower when the kth
nearest neighbor is far away.
Notice, that this k in kth nearest neighbor
is a hyperparameter that we need to choose,
because with its help, UMAP makes a density
estimation to find the right local radius.
If k is big, then more global
structure is preserved,
if k is small, then the radius decreases,
and the local structure is more preserved.
So the right k could give the perfect balance
between local and global structure preservation,
but there are rarely any recipes for
finding the optimum automatically.
Some trial and error is required, since
k depends on each dataset individually.
But not all k neighbors are
equal, since each have different
distances from the point we are looking at.
Then the connections between each point and their
neighbors get a weight, a connection probability,
where points which are far away, are weighted
less and get lower connection probability.
Now that this high-dimensional graph is
constructed, it is ready to be projected to lower
dimensions. This graph projection algorithm is too
much for Ms. Coffee Bean to explain in detail in
this video, but you can imagine this projection
as taking the high-dimensional graph, with their
edges being springs, where each spring is stronger
as the edge probability increases.
Which means that points connected by
high weighted edges are more likely to stay
together in the lower dimensional space,
because the spring holds these points together.
And perhaps interesting to notice is that these
spring forces are rotationally symmetric
which leads to clusters sometimes landing
on one side after one UMAP run and on
the other side after another projection.
So UMAP has two main strengths over the other
famous graph-based dimensionality reduction
technique called t-SNE: It is faster due to its
optimizations and strong mathematical foundations
and it also has a better balance between
locality and globality in clustering.
Take for example this visualization from the
awesome blog from Google PAIR linked below.
We have this mammoth in 3D on the left
and we can see side by side how UMAP and
t-SNE map this 3D mammoth into two dimensions.
We can play around with the number of neighbors
taken into account when constructing the high
dimensional graph and we can clearly see how
low numbers focus on the local structure, while
higher numbers more on the global structure.
The minimum distance parameter allows to
specify how tightly the algorithm will map
points into the target low dimensional space. A
high minimum distance will spread the points more.
But it is important to notice that a
stepwise change of these two parameters
continuously changes the UMAP result.
T-SNE on the other side is not that
great in this aspect, because when changing the
parameter of t-SNE, t-SNE's result completely
changes. We really recommend you to play around
yourself with all examples in this blog post.
So far we have seen examples
where UMAP maps from 3D to 2D,
but the visualizations you have seen so far,
are toy examples. They are just for us to
get an intuition about the inner workings of
the UMAP dimensionality reduction algorithm.
What UMAP excels at, is reducing from a lot
of dimensions. Here is a real-world example of
784 dimensional MNIST data containing handwritten
digits. It would be nice if we could reduce their
dimensions to two or three so we can visualize
this pixel space the digits are living in.
For this, we can write a little Python
code to load the MNIST data, to load the
UMAP package for dimensionality reduction,
and a visualization package of your liking.
We like babyplots and you will see why.
We read in the data and we see we have 60,000
training instances of 28 times 28
pixels, which are together the 784
dimensions we plan to reduce from.
For reducing, we fit and apply the
UMAP algorithm. And we do it once for two
dimensions, and again for three dimensions.
We reduced to 2d and 3d to show you
what a cool thing babyplots can do:
It takes both the 3d and 2d embedding and
can animate a transition between the two.
How cool is that? Hereby we can see that UMAP
could already cluster almost all handwritten
digits together. Meaning that UMAP here worked
as an unsupervised clustering algorithm.
Also, we can see how useful a 3d visualization
can be over just 2d, where more complicated
structures and relations can be visualized.
If you want to visualize these things in 3D
yourself in either R, Javascript or
Python and load your interactive 3d
plots into a PowerPoint presentation to show
to everybody, check out the babyplots website!
This was it from Ms. Coffee Bean. Read the paper
if you are interested in the mathematical theory
and proofs behind UMAP. Find it linked in
the description below. Or watch the first
author (Leland McInnes) of the UMAP paper
presenting his UMAP invention linked below.
Now go and reduce your dimensions with UMAP!
Ok, bye!